bonjour à tous aujourd'hui un épisode
très spécial car j'ai quelque chose
d'important à vous annoncer j'ai écrit
une bande dessinée si d'entre vous qui
me suivent sur Instagram ont pu voir
depuis quelques temps que je partageais
des petits aperçus de ce projet et bien
c'est officiel je vous annonce que vous
pouvez dès aujourd'hui précommander ma
bande dessinée qui s'appellera filorama
les petites histoires des grands
philosophes ça faisait très longtemps
que j'avais envie d'explorer un nouveau
format de vulgarisation pour prolonger
le travail que je fais sur ma chaîne et
c'est là que m'est venu l'idée de la
bande dessinée puisqu'une bande dessinée
c'est ludique c'est divertissant et sur
un plan purement pédagogique une bande
dessinée ça offre des possibilités
incroyables alors évidemment je ne suis
pas seul sur ce projet je travaille avec
un dessinateur professionnel qui
s'appelle Jules Jules btrx je vous mets
quelques vidéos de lui en train de
travailler sur la BD et
contrepartie qu'on a prévu pour vous et
au niveau des contreparties vous allez
voir qu'on a mis le paquet vous pouvez
choisir de seulement pré-commer la BD
vous pouvez avoir votre nom sur la page
de remerciement vous pouvez recevoir la
bande dessinée signée par mes soins vous
pouvez même avoir votre propre
personnage dans la BD ce qui est quand
même sympa et là informations très
importante je vous annonce que les 1000
premiers contributeurs recevront chacun
un ticket d'or un ticket d'or qui vous
permettra de participer au grand tirage
au sort qui aura lieu à la fin de
l'accompagne lune et l'un d'entre vous
se verra offrir le pack complet d'une
valeur de 1000 euros bref je vous laisse
découvrir tout ça directement sur la
page Ulule suivez le lien dans la
description vous verrez on vous a tout
expliqué en détail maintenant la
question que vous vous posez sans doute
c'est de quoi va parler cette bande
dessinée et bien le principe de cette
bande dessinée c'est de vous immerger
dans la vie quotidienne de 10
philosophes de Platon à Jean-Paul Sartre
en passant par Spinoza shopenhauer ou
encore Nietzsche au travers de 10
petites histoires inspirées de leur vie
je dis inspirer parce qu'on s'est appuyé
sur des anecdotes réelles sur des
histoires que ces philosophes ont
vraiment vécu et vous allez voir qu'ils
ont parfois vécu des choses assez
cocasse et on a intégré ces anecdotes
dans des scénarios tantôt humoristiques
tantôt épique voire tragique donc vous
verrez Jean-Paul Sartre se faire
poursuivre par des homards géants après
avoir pris trop de mescaline vous verrez
Socrate en pleine scène de ménage avec
sa femme le jour de son procès bref vous
verrez les philosophes comme vous ne les
avez jamais vu et tout l'intérêt de
cette bande dessinée c'est que vous
n'allez pas seulement passer un moment
divertissant vous allez aussi apprendre
et quand je dis apprendre je parle sur
le plan philosophique je parle de la
pensée des auteurs puisqu'on a eu une
idée assez originale avec Jules qui est
d'alterner des moments histoire et des
moments courts quatre pages d'histoire
dans lesquelles vous allez suivre les
mésaventures philosophe dans sa vie
quotidienne suivie de deux pages de
cours dans lesquelles je résume les
grandes lignes de sa pensée donc si vous
êtes débutant vous allez vraiment
pouvoir vous initier à la philosophie de
manière ludique et si vous avez déjà des
connaissances en philosophie vous allez
apprendre des choses croustillantes sur
la vie des philosophes et voir comment
leur philosophie pouvait se traduire
dans leur vie et comme une image vomimo
le mieux c'est de vous montrer
directement ce que ça donne sur l'une
des histoires qu'on a déjà réalisées
avec Jules à savoir l'histoire de
Schopenhauer donc shopenhauer vous le
savez c'était un grand misanthrope
c'était quelqu'un qui n'avait pas un
grand amour pour l'humanité c'est moins
qu'on puisse dire donc l'idée qu'on a eu
c'est de mettre en scène un shopenhauer
à la fois aigri et drôle parce que
sarcastique parce que sans aucun filtre
qui dit tout le mal qu'il pense de Hegel
qui insulte sa voisine qui passe tout
son temps à maudire l'humanité et
l'histoire s'achève sur comment shopenha
est passé à deux doigts de se
réconcilier avec l'humanité donc le plus
simple c'est que vous alliez voir
directement tout ça sur la page Ulule on
a publié les six pages consacrées à
shopenhauer et ça vous donnera un aperçu
assez précis de ce que vous allez
trouver dans la BD et donc comme je vous
le disais tout à l'heure
Ulule c'est un site de financement de
projet ce qui veut dire que c'est
uniquement grâce à vos précommandes que
le projet pourra être concrétisé et que
la BD pour avoir le jour pourquoi je
vous dis ça parce que la BD est encore
en cours de création on a écrit tous les
scénarios Jul a fait la moitié des
storyboard les planches sur shopenhauer
sont terminées mais il y a encore du
travail et la BD ne sera terminée que
dans quelques mois s'il y a des
dessinateurs parmi vous vous savez à
quel point ça peut être long de faire
une bande dessinée surtout quand on est
perfectionniste et quand on a des
exigences sur la qualité de ce qu'on
veut offrir au public et c'est le cas de
Jules il tient vraiment à rendre un
travail propre un travail de niveau
professionnel et moi aussi je veux que
cette bande dessinée soit la plus
réussie possible que vous soyez heureux
de l'avoir entre vos mains que ce ne
soit pas simplement un achat de soutien
c'est une bande dessinée que vous allez
pouvoir offrir pour Noël pour les
anniversaires de vos proches ou de vos
enfants du coup n'hésitez pas en
commander plusieurs et n'hésitez pas non
plus à partager la page Ulule à faire
connaître ce projet à toutes les
personnes que ça pourrait intéresser
parce qu'encore une fois c'est grâce à
vous et uniquement grâce à vous que ce
projet pourra aboutir et permettra de
dépoussiérer un peu l'image que certains
se font de la philosophie ce qui me
suivent depuis longtemps savent que je
ne suis pas du genre à faire les choses
à moitié et je peux vous garantir que
cette bande dessinée elle sera bien elle
sera même très bien voilà vous savez
tout je vous donne rendez-vous sur la
page Ulule sur laquelle je publierai
régulièrement des nouvelles concernant
l'avancement du projet objectif 100%
avant la fin de la semaine prochaine
merci à tous pour votre attention et je
vous dis à très bientôt pour de
nouvelles aventures philosophiques
[Musique]